looking at Plato's Phaedo a good portion
of it consists in articles you guys got
that but not all right what does it
we'll make something in our you know we
have a couple different ways in which it
gives this term if we say don't argue
with me what do we often mean not
necessarily the same kind of argument
yeah I guess some people are so like so
controlling that you can disagree with
them you're making an argument right
even though you might just be saying I
think you're wrong that's not an
argument yeah but some people see that
as arguing what else do we do yeah
different viewpoints different
viewpoints are represented but when we
when we talk about argument those are
towards this sort of what else angry and
yell at each other you're a jerk no
you're a jerk that's not philosophical
argument philosophical argument involves
different viewpoints because you don't
argue with people or even argue with
yourself
unless you have something that you
disagree about so disagreements also a
part of it but there has to be more than
just you know I say this I say this and
I'm just repeating that know this know
this sometimes people try to you know
convince each other that way if you
shout louder maybe then people will
believe you they trying to appeal to
emotions like guilt or things like that
if you think I'll like you that's still
not philosophical argument what does it
take that if you're if you want to
convince somebody or if you're unsure
about something and you want to arrive
at being sure about what is it what does
it take for you yeah okay no those are
two very different types fact is a very
slippery term that we we often invoke
but you know more than you start looking
at this the more you start finding the
facts are kind of being hard to it's
thing because there's always if you gets
it you know even people quote things
things or stuff like that but then you
have to interpret it right but that's
part of the process evidence let's say
evidence is bad again you know what
counts as evidence sometimes up for
grabs but and they said logic so logic
what comes to your mind when you say
logic yeah something that just kind of
fits into what you're discussing if it's
kind of a little bit off topic it's not
logical to the argument so that's an
important consideration relevance you
know you can't just bring up anything
that it's logically connected and you
said fit into that that's part of it as
well when you're you're being logically
it's tying things together now just
tying them together doesn't
automatically make it you know logically
valid and logically sound but you're on
the way that you're at least doing
better than somebody saying I think X
and if you disagree with me you're wrong
what else goes along with argument in
that sense or logic yeah in some cases
both sides perceive themselves to be
right well you know that's all mostly
just the case
now if the argument is taking place sort
of but then you it's almost like there's
a conflict with you know one part of you
saying I think this is the this is the
case I think this is the case and it
doesn't have to be about philosophy just
think about when you doubted whether a
friend was going to actually follow
through on something they said they
would do whether you could trust this
person party was saying yeah I can trust
this person another part of you saying
you can't trust this person what did
they do other than just say
yeah can yes very good
so when we have arguments there does
have to be relevance things going to be
connected and I think that just saying
you know providing the the Y is a very
basic way to express this you know we're
gonna in formal logic class we could
talk about providing reasons for your
belief or something along those lines
right but whatever reasons for your
these things that say why sometimes we
have other things how you know we
provide explanations how does this
happen
you notice Socrates does that some some
things as well but yep saying why and
you know can you argue about the why
yeah you can go further and maybe
somebody doesn't accept all of the
explanation or the justification that
you get and then you have to do some
more argument right but hopefully here's
here's where we get to something else
it's over if you don't want it just to
go on forever
what do you have to do ya find an end
point so it's that much yeah three
o'clock
no what once somebody is either their
mind has changed or is accepting of the
reasons okay so that's on the sort of
the
okay trial I think that's along the same
lines you do want to come to some sort
of agreement at the end that's important
but some arguments we you know when we
have opposing sides we don't arrive at
that and then we say oh I always write
what do you have to have in order to get
the ball rolling crew for something
supporting your why when you do that
think about it this way if you're gonna
provide what's like you're gonna provide
what do you need to be getting from
somebody who doesn't agree with it I was
just gonna say what makes it persuasive
some of those you know providing the fly
but there's something that you have to
begin from that's actually important to
Aristotle says that all the things that
we you know use to convince people
characters like when you make a third
person question what they are arguing
for or against oh that's that's good too
is you get them to depart from their
position you're actually taking away
something from them in that case I'm
just gonna say you catered for words
their perspective now we're getting
towards the where I'm trying to steer
this so if you're going to cater towards
their perspective yeah
inspiration really like because I don't
yeah become revelation about something
well that protective helmet yeah
especially if they're they don't see
something and then suddenly you know
something makes sense to them as I now I
see your perspective but let's go back
to this so how do you cater to another
person's perspective who disagrees or
you just give up altogether you're right
I'm wrong that would yeah that would
work something even more basic I'll give
it to you if you don't agree on anything
at all then you can't argue with
somebody meaning they don't have any
common basis and this might actually
involve some give-and-take - that's kind
of good you might you know you might say
well I'll give up on this point that
I've been insisting on but you have to
give me get to grant me this and then
once you do that you can start applying
poll logical machinery and say look if
this is the case and this has got to be
the case doesn't it isn't that the you
know the way it works yeah okay well
that's the case that doesn't this also
have to be the case and after a while
they start seeing where it's headed okay
I get that
- well then this has to be the case -
right this is where you want it to go if
you want to you know whether it's
philosophy business fashion
merchandising pick anything you like if
you want to be able to get somebody else
to see things your way you have to find
some common ground that you share with
them that often isn't actually fighting
the common ground and then once you've
done that then you can start providing
you know reasons for for why you see
things the way you do you can steer them
in your direction so philosophical
argument has to do that
yeah there's two things that Socrates
assumes as common ground throughout
these arguments in the Phaedo and one of
the other we generally call the forms so
a very quick run down this so we keep
these in mind what's the doctrine of
recollection that notion
you know our learning processes for at
least some of the things that we're
learning are not actually learning
something new we actually have the
knowledge inside of us we just sort of
forgot it for a while it got buried and
somebody like Socrates could come along
and ask a bunch of questions and get us
to see that we actually do know what it
is that we're looking for if we recall
it we remember it and along with this
you know where did we first learn about
these things previous life so some sort
of previous existence doctrine forms
that's a very important photonic
doctrine it's core to this philosophy
it's the idea that there are these
absolutes unchanging eternal
forms that things that we see and
experience and feel participated and
they include things like justice so
there's an absolute justice out there
somewhere he doesn't really say where it
is in this dialogue there's an absolute
justice out there that all the justices
that we see in this world participate in
and that's what makes them what they are
the forum is the reality everything else
they're just sort of copies what do you
know about copies you guys well use copy
machines are they as good as the
original
not usually I mean I suppose you could
like you know put it on nicer paper you
know still it's not quite the same then
because ever like make copies of the
copy how does that work
it's fades yeah and then now imagine
making copies of copies of copies of
copies that's that's sort of like a
justice that that we experienced as
compared to absolute justice or absolute
equality and in other dialogues Plato
will frame this in terms of like you
know there being an ideal form of human
being or gas or things like that it gets
a lot more complicated them but we're
just gonna like stick with you know
things like equality or you know
greatness or small minutes or is like
that so the idea is that document forms
it's also sometimes called the doctrine
of participation there are these ideals
out there they are
realities on their own and the things
that we experience see smell hear those
are just copies that participate so you
got to grant these things for else the
arguments are not going to be very
convincing before that I want to take a
little detour for just a second and he
asked a few questions
yes so how many of you believe that
there is something like what he's
talking about as a soul which is a
separate thing that's you that's
different from your body so different
from that you know meat and bones that
composes you also different from the
brain that's up in here your skull how
many of you believe that quite a few how
many of you believe something that would
be opposed to that like look this is if
there's meat bones and brains and organs
and off that's all we get when they have
dies the human genome nice few people
I'm gonna do don't really know how many
of you hope that there's some sort of
that rather than no but you hope that
there's some sort of soul something
that's sort of I just passed up and you
know now I ask yourself what would it
take to convince you that there actually
is some sort of survival in that stuff
there actually is a soul now not only is
there a soul and that soul continues on
because some of the discussion about the
salt here sees the soul is something
that I could wear out could disappear
yeah could you relief it to say memory
or latest eBay you yourself leave United
sense that that's an interesting
question
yeah that's you in a way provided the
memories are accurate we often you know
make the memories of the Dead
you know quite nicer than they turned
out to be start doing histories
although people in old time touch upon
that we're like the Weaver when he grows
old and loses a skill and yes leaves out
list him that's the body that outlives
in the neck is you're talking about
something like thing right
we say things when people have died like
oh there's the witness so long as we
remember them right to try to console
people yeah and you know when you hear
that kind of stuff this is my experience
and I've had a lot of people die happy
both my parents are dead all my
grandparents are dead
great ants mostly in uncle's best friend
died on me college girlfriend was in the
army so you know I heard a lot of things
along those lines and I think some
people find it
consoling but if you start thinking
about you're like yeah but what if I
just remembered them that's not really
that visit well I gave you for instance
you're in the Army I was in brain
quarters yeah and they say you know you
now became something bigger than
yourself
you're never forgotten also you may not
be remembered by name but yeah whether
correlation with an organization
different then you're not talking about
just an individual being remembered by
their you know a friend's family stuff
like that you're putting yourself into a
larger project something bigger than
yourself
did you find that consoling that I did I
think I can find stuff like that
consoling in a way that I wouldn't find
you know the notion of like
my kids are gonna remember me quite as
consoling because there's a greater
meaning but there's also kind of a sense
of losing your personality of becoming
anonymous yes but it's still a decision
that you have made in your legacy or if
you really want to get philosophical
your assessment yeah I think there's a
lot of ways that one could think about
that as well you know even if it's not
an organization one dies doing something
that one knows there's a good chance of
dying because it's the right thing to do
and it's going to help somebody else you
know nobody else does even remember it
is it is it still worth doing some
people speaking out because I you know
even some people who were eating this
like Albert Camus would say good to do
the part because the meaning that's
overall with this pain of fondly it like
consoling of thing about after death or
anything like that yeah wouldn't
theoretically anything that someone
believes in or puts that their actual
faith or hope into through we have that
power it could become something
completely obscure but if they think it
truly yep is it like the comedian who
says you know all the different world
religions are all saying different
things and maybe the one guy who's out
there saying that you know god is a some
golf clubs
hitting golf balls around for all
eternity maybe he is actually right we
actually all get to heaven it turns out
to be so the golf clubs and God we're
like what was a big surprise in acid I
said my prophet to tell you yeah I mean
there's something to that
the trouble is part of part of any
person's life and it's not just
philosophers you see this is a lot many
read novels when you're facing death and
when not necessarily your own death it
can be other people's death especially a
death of a child or you know the first
death in your family or something like
that there there's a tendency to want
meaning it actually makes sense out of
it yeah this is part of what makes us
human
dogs don't worry about other dogs dying
than their own death were you naked that
way maybe maybe the dolphins and maybe
the the higher Apes share something like
this we're not quite sure but we
certainly do it as part of our part of
our our cultural experience no matter
what culture you look at one could just
sort of convince oneself here's the
answer I'm not going to think about
anything else you know just do the
innominate kind of thing right it
doesn't work for for too long for most
people and that's part of why we have
these kind of responses and not just in
the Phaedo but again and the sacred
scriptures of all different religions in
the epic literature like the story of
Gilgamesh he goes down to try to bring
his friend back from from the dead
because you want to know this guy have
to die there there's a there's something
corrosive about that arose our attempts
to say I'm just going to believe
okay we want something that provides us
a little more certainty and just sort of
believing is one way to try to do that
but again this ties in with what's
distinctively human in us we are
creatures that think about things that
want to know that have a desire to have
things make sense and so that's part of
what's going on with these arguments if
you could actually provide an argument
now let's say now we're actually going
to live after we die
that would be a lot more and so on and
you notice this is kind of an important
play about the dialogue who is Socrates
actually gets old
no I was not the beater
um he's killing his friends like yeah
they're dirty they're saying we're gonna
lose this great friend of ours well he's
the one dying Craig do you think he'd be
more worried about where every breathe
yeah they're they're very upset and
actually some of them so upset that
they're frying all the doors no Socrates
gets honor he says hey we stopped the
women away so we weren't gonna have this
sort of nonsense and actually has kept
funny tip is the Greek the Greek to wait
when you're crying
Odysseus if you ever read The Odyssey he
loses his men all the time he's actually
sad about as they're rowing they're
crying for their lost comrades there is
there's a sort of detention
okay so all of it aside let's actually
look at some of these departments and I
think you can divide them into two
groups of arguments that are made in the
dialogue now this probably doesn't
strike you right away it's probably kind
of a mishmash for you the first couple
times reading through there is the kind
of dancing around at the beginning where
Socrates and simian
back and forth about things and the
things I put up there before dr.
recollection doc conforms get brought up
a lot there's some arguments blessed
that are made they're not particularly
good arguments they've got some holes in
them even if you actually do believe you
know recollection and the doctrine forms
and then sue me as Incubus there's an
important turning point where they say
yeah we're not convinced
you know Socrates has given them
arguments they're like yeah those don't
cut it what are our worries and simius
comes up with one metaphor maybe the
soul is like a harmony KB's comes up
with another metaphor maybe it's like an
old man who leaves cloaks and his last
focal ism can you deal with this
Socrates
so let's you know let's do things in
order let's look at the first arguments
first and then we'll look at the more
interesting arguments a little bit later
so the first agree that the kbase
expresses about immortality is you know
maybe the soul and he's saying yeah
there is a soul but maybe it's something
more like when we think about
personality or our memories or something
like that maybe the body is really the
locus for who we are and the body dies
whatever there is of us just kind of
disappears it dissipates breaks down
this is a real word isn't it
so Socrates comes up with this argument
from opposites and this might have been
very confusing to you at the beginning
if it was it's in part because you're
not used to the process dialectic you're
just starting out with Socrates and
Plato and that's fine you know some of
you this may actually like hook you in
and you may turn into philosophy majors
those of you who are undeclared so they
may you know actually
major thing happens that's great
that doesn't happen that's a okay too
because everybody ends up having to do
philosophy whether you major in it or
not and dialectic is one of the main
ways we do it dialectic is this process
questioning the answer but it's also the
process of finding arguments and if
you're not used to that it's it's kind
of you know tricky at first so you might
not have thought all this the first time
around so Socrates starts out by using
this principle they're opposites
what is that yeah kind of like a balance
of being dirty game and game take the
field camp one without the other
yeah there's there's actually some some
appeal later on to something kind of
like that and having to do it the whole
universe these are not a Vulcan or some
Indian Yahoo that's Chinese all they
come out of being short or yeah that's
it sounds really tricky but this is
really what he's saying so a big thing
that gets smaller you know what would be
like a big thing that would get smaller
right small thing where'd you get a
small thing from a big thing
small things eventually become big
things sometimes
right and those those big things came
out of small things and he gives some
other examples you're stronger weaker
you guys are presumably stronger than
you were when you were younger right
other or you must have done some you
know we're super strong baby no baby a
toddler right what was that three not a
toddler that's best it's a small child
you were originally weaker not stronger
as you get older of course nobody wants
you to like keep yourself in shape
you're gonna go
things are gonna things come out of
there opposites they move between these
two poles there's a duality there the
Chinese they actually did associate this
with yeah so like in Yong it was like
darkness strong weak advancing retreated
those sorts of things
one thing that he doesn't talk about
here and this might be a problem for
this male and female I don't think you
can fight well yeah I was once a woman
and so now I'm a man you know came out
of the one became the other that doesn't
actually see itself necessarily hope
although if you think about with this
doctrine of souls you know being
reincarnated over and over again you
just happened to be women and in the
bodies that you currently have but
previous lives
presumably you'd have had different
different genders it could be you know
that's interesting to the doctors of the
countries that believe in reincarnation
the cultures rather that believe in
reincarnation
quite often gender is tied with you know
whether you're a good person or a bad
person also location is we were Hindus
for example being born here in the
United States sign that we all screwed
up in the previous life because we're
not an Indian married actually and all I
get to learn
stuff like that so we got almost bad
people if we if we accept that that no
should be encouraging okay so large
things you can small things and there's
a process going back and forth right
there's a process of going from larger
to smaller what do we call that getting
smaller or de munition there's a process
of going from smaller to larger call
this getting larger or increase and
we've got a lot of synonym schools
now what about death and life are there
living things that go from being living
for being dead things yeah we see it all
the time right just drive on nine sooner
or later you can see a deer that was a
living thing that's a death thing other
things are eating it and if they're not
careful they'll become dead things too
about cars and violence
you know um the question then is is
there a process of going from death to
life
and Sark to you says this is the process
of coming and how does that make sense
well yeah
you can say that it circled like
something guys yeah now this is an
interesting thing to think about
we do have experience with dead things
and they're seeing other living things
coming out like well you don't think
about fertilizer but it's fertilizing
Manor Den things actually what comes up
fertilizer ulcers are good things living
things right
people used to used to believe a long
time ago that that rotten meat
spontaneously generated you know fly
larvae noise Socrates doesn't have that
idea
he thinks that we're talking about some
individual thing and something you go
from being living to being dead but
something could also go from being dead
to being living that individual thing
not something new coming out of it and
the reason you think this is remember
what is what is death it's the
separation of the body and soul so the
body the soul Manton fused together like
this so they go along for a while in
life and then BOOM something happens
safe Falls hits the guy in the head he's
dead
was bodies dead body goes over here and
dissipates soul continues on and now
it's dead soul doesn't have a body
it's separate so it's dead in that sense
and then when it's put into another body
what do you it's come back to life right
this is dependent on you having this
notion of reincarnation for you to say
well I'm gonna say it once the soul
leaves the body then you have the
afterlife
leave it yes whatever your heaven or
hell or purgatory is you know that's
your that's going for life yeah
where is Elysium feels or Hades gonna be
like yeah so now Socrates says you know
living things are generated from from
the dead how would that happen well the
dead have to exist somewhere that's
exactly what we're sitting here they
have to exist somewhere from the living
to be able to come from them through the
process of coming employed and that's
explained by the separation song now the
the thing about the universe
imagine these processes going back and
forth back and forth all the time
now imagine that everything gets bigger
and nothing ever gets smaller well the
university are not pretty so there'd be
no room for anything all right what if
everything were to get smaller
nothing wherever to get there only one
side bigger ah yeah that's where I see
comparison now that's something that's
not getting spelled out here yeah well I
mean kind of to be devil's advocate and
you know yeah trees gonna be figured out
Rock topsail ooh there's at least
comparison possibility yeah but
everything's getting bigger and bigger
and bigger still at the same time yeah
pretty soon the tree of the rock and the
hill gonna be the same thing fuse
together
we're gonna death of life what you know
we know that things are dying could it
be that everything is dying
and this is not you know too convincing
all right well so see where it goes so
if everything was dying and nothing was
coming to life what would eventually
happen you know what that evidence that
swallowed up and death now Socrates
takes that is an impossibility and I
think that part of what you have to read
into that is the notion the Greeks often
have this idea that the world is not
eternal had been going on for a very
very very long time so if everything was
dying and nothing else was coming to
life then you know there should be less
than less and less less living things
and eventually we'd be in kind of a
wasteland and we should probably already
be there by now so there really
shouldn't be this experience of moving
the fusion of life and that's pretty
much where he goes with this he doesn't
fully smell it I think probably he
hasn't in mind something like the notion
of life would cease to have any meaning
for us but he doesn't spell it out and
it's not a particularly great argument
c-bass says he goes on to the same rings
of the doctor the recollection says you
know this would actually make a lot of
sense if we accept the doctrine of
recollection there has to be some place
that the dead were yes Socrates actually
raises a problem
kind of an interesting education on the
doctor collection it says well you know
you could have learned it with you
freshmen born did that I would you
forgot how would it how would that come
you actually have to have had it in a
previous life and then forgotten and at
this point the dialogue terms a
different way yeah Samia says we've
overlooked something let's say this we
buy all this stuff
we actually buy the doctoral reflection
does that get you that you're gonna be
worn it yet that you're gonna have
another life after this you know you
have a previous life does that get you
that you're gonna have one after you die
this why not oh I guess in some beliefs
that you are reincarnated because you
didn't finish some things we're sold oh
yeah not that rest you know it's
bothersome or whatever so if you
completed what you needed to in this
life then oh yeah you know if you look
at again the big world religions that
believe in reincarnation like
after a while the goal is not just a bit
better at new life the goals like finish
up with that got more reburied with all
that and it actually is for Socrates too
if you're looking at what he's talking
about be able soul if you practice
philosophy and they're purified do
really really well you want to build
yourself from coffee and things like
that then when you die you won't be you
won't want to there's that possibility
but it also could be that for the rest
of us you know of course laughs you know
we've been born a whole bunch of times
before this but then the next time
around that's it we're done that could
be the case yeah so Samia says maybe the
the soul you know maybe this explains
something maybe that explains something
for this so Socrates says what we get at
another argument here and here we spirit
thinking about simple things or
accomplice so what can you say about
compound of things like anything that's
got moving parts what's the problem with
things with moving parts they break down
yeah sooner or later something goes bad
on them and it breaks down what's your
body look your body any moving parts
moving them right now all right moving
your seats to some degree thinking about
things like your your now this isn't a
big problem for most yeah but think
about things like your joints right a
lot of moving parts man what's the
problem that's great because unless it's
get around if you do all sorts of cool
things
what's the problem
we're way yeah you like actually we're
home like the cartilage it keeps things
from rubbing against each other nowadays
they give you tech tinea knees or I
think they're really going past that you
know so we can overcome that but then
you got more of a moving parts and
presumably those who wear out after a
while right they need to do hurts down
other organs but everything breaks down
sooner or later so everything that's
complex breaks down dissolves becomes
other than what it is they change over
time you don't remain the same so that
fits your experience right think about
this truck right truck was here in my
hand now some chalkboards changed over
time it's a longer exactly the same kind
of thing certainly not in the shape that
it was order actually I'll use the whole
thing up probably have this class
session sooner later
think about your bodies you know what
are we know for medical science every
one of the cells that you have in your
body and I hope you started out with you
know cells live maybe about seven years
or so then they died and replaced by
other cells you're not in a certain way
the same thing as you were seven years
ago we call you about the same name more
or less the same shape would you look at
photo of you you guys are now about you
know eighteen nineteen twenty
we didn't look at a photo of you from
when you were say twelve and we can
probably recognize yeah that's that's
her
that's him beer not the same the bodies
change with other things
well the Platonic forms let's think
about those those are abundant change
those are eternal those are always the
same why because they they don't break
down there's no moving parts they're not
composit and ask yourself this how do
you perceive these sort of complex
things that your body
and everyone want to be a look at the
mirror this morning are these you know
the last couple days you saw somebody
looking back cranking out a vampire we
had a bigger vampire like having to do
your makeup you know you can tie a tie
all the time wouldn't be a problem with
it because it's key it ties in sides not
part of your body suppose eventually the
technically speaking of makeup you
should I just like give to see the
mirror we've got really technicals may
have higher things but you get the idea
you can see yourself because you your
body at least is a complex thing people
who work out then watch yourself in a
mirror the whole time you know they're
fit their band again that as well
anything any sort of comp is a thing
that's got matter you can see it more so
you can sense it in some way we can
measure what about these forms according
to the doctor that's formed you can't
see them smell them touch them and feel
them so how do you actually perceive
them
it's her dialectic it comes in we we
perceived them in part through talking
about them but what is that provoking
with the agent in the talking is just
getting something that you have what's
up good idea uh yeah actually the forms
another word for them is the ideas play
those ideas these are ideas that are
believing in what do you believe with
yeah reflecting these are all activities
of what face would fit in there to faith
is what is it that that has made that
flax that what does that part of you
well the soul and yet the mind
specifically the mind you perceive them
through the mind and you can't see them
because you can actually think about and
you can only access on through now
what's your soul wait show me your soul
there's this great scene and Planet of
the Apes the new version where you know
of course you know the apes are how I
like to know the humans and and there's
debates about among the Apes whether
human beings have souls and one of the
characters is this general is played by
Tim Roth he actually grabs a human and
Mark Wahlberg I think it opens up his
mouth and he like looks in there and he
says I don't see any soul in there
throws on the side and the idea is
supposed to be off but they can't see
the soul it doesn't exist but is the
soul that kind of thing the soul some
sort of complex material thing no it's
it's much more like the form and now
this is an argument which is saying two
things are similar to each other so they
probably have the same thing qualities
they should they should share those who
comes is what we call an argument by
analogy the soul is is much more like
than us and these things
you live forever so shouldn't Seoul go
on tremors and assault the unchanging
eternal self saying what do you think
yeah just maybe though what's just an
idea any of it although this is just
that yes that's all that's all you
really have as a matter of fact even
given your experiences of material
things you have ideas so that's not
really an objection to there's other
problems you could raise you see
anything in here that might not fit the
soul if we accept that there is a soul
for working at my Posse's yeah
yeah that's the small change over time
Socrates at least does seem to think
that it does because you learn things
right that's change in you isn't it
or if you go from being a good person to
a bad person or a bad person to a good
person isn't that change should make you
a little leery of this that's arguable
yeah Socrates traces are you know he had
something else he said well you don't
think about it this way here's another
analogy does the soul run the body or
does the body around the soul
I think I'll think about it if you do
souls tripping up think about your
personality does your does your body
make you your personality do things
where you get to decide what you're
gonna do with your body yeah well I
think give an example eight sometimes
those random mood swing you cannot
explain yeah they're revealing there are
some problems with this this idea you
know about depression or psychosis are
there any drugs you can dig for that
sort of thing and then those effects
what they affect the body and then the
body that is a given deterring changes
the mood or at least keeps you from
hearing voices
one manifestation of it random ideations
they talk about so yeah I mean it
doesn't actually look like the body can
in turn do things to the soul but for
the most part in normal life as it is
your body that got you here and eight
o'clock in the morning
to study philosophy where is it your
your soul your mind your personality
inside crap it's eight o'clock I gotta
get off gotta get myself over there like
Socrates says you know hey if it was
just up to my body I wouldn't be sitting
here in this cell how'd he got the hell
out here when you know credo offered me
a chance to get out of here I'd be I'd
be in Thebes by now so the soul actually
has at least some degree of control over
the body now think about the divine and
the material yeah you can accept some
premises about the Greek way of looking
at things back then but if you do have a
belief in some sort of you know gods
that are very powerful or perhaps even
all-powerful don't they rule over the
rest of the world the rest of the
material so what is the soul more like
it's more like the divine isn't it again
this is this is an argument by analogy
how many of you are convinced by this
argument notice I'm not reason like how
many of you were tempted at least to be
convinced by the time it's not a very
convincing huh
so ask yourself at this point before we
go out and look at our arguments why is
Plato introducing arguments that he
knows have holes in them why is he
putting them into a dialogue you see
people respond very good these are sort
of like obstacle courses platonic
dialogues except you're getting a seat
you're going to go through the obstacle
course with other people and sometimes
the arguments are gonna be very good
sometimes they're not going to be very
good when they're not very good part of
what's going on is Plato as well
offering you a chance to enter into the
dialectic he's offering you the
opportunity to come into the dialogue to
say hey wait a second here that's not a
good argument
what could Socrates is set to make that
a better argument Plato leaves these
these loose ends untied so that you can
actually pick them up and that's up to
you of it and each one of you when you
go through these I would imagine that
some of you were struck at some points
in the dialogue and said yeah this this
doesn't actually make sense but wait a
second what if this I imagine some of
you did that somebody will probably be
doing that when you go back to your you
know where you're going and then read it
again but probably those of you who did
that didn't do it on the same parking
lot
Plato perhaps in a lot of different
arguments it's sort of like offering you
this gigantic playground or dialectic
for improving your capacity to to
understand arguments or thinking about
these sorts of things he's not actually
saying any of you have to believe in any
of these particular things or find these
arguments convincing he's blocking them
to you and some of them that he's
offering are not some of them that he's
offering he knows that they are damaged
goods and he's saying well maybe you
could make them better but then he also
does a lot for what at least what he
thinks are better hardness so let's look
at those simius and he makes offer to
other possible views and let's let's
look very briefly at these what is
worried the soul is a harmony and we
don't actually use liars much in our
heart music dude so think about a good
time all right you're all familiar with
guitars I think you got a guitar how
many of you ever played a time so so
what if limbs actually tuned right and
you strum it
what should you hear you're six tones
right also beat those faults drink it
there's other kinds of things but what
should you hear what's the technical
term for that cuz it's a Canon our MIDI
yeah and it's the Canon harmony we call
it a chord right so if you you don't
know any chords on the guitar we have
one song and it's just the same thing
you could play on that guitar and then
if you learn a few chords what are you
doing and putting your fingers on the
frets you're changing the length of the
strings so now you make a C chord from
going from an E chord you go to a C
chord
and then you make it you know what meant
it or diminished or all these these
other fancy things right
and you can play arpeggios to one string
to another string to another string the
religious truth that's another kind of
harmony now thinking about you know punk
musicians and some of the rocket rollers
what were they what do they like to do
with their guitars go next what are they
sometimes in the stage show rather
smashing smashing guitar and if you
smash the guitar what happens to the
hardest thing well you know there's no
good you smash the guitar right it's
that well it's not a little out of sync
it's not like you need to tune it at
that you smashed it there's no guitar
anymore no guitar no harmony right the
harmony only exists because the guitar
or the musical instrument
this actually just cut the strings you
wanna stop somebody playing you know ice
of course they're playing cut their
strings now you don't to listen to it
could be useful the doors all right but
things can be replaced
you smash the guitar there yeah there
could be debates about you know when you
play a chord like play the chord wants
Thank You Lady Anne is it the same chord
you're playing or is it two different
chords that sound saying they don't
worry about those those are very
interesting interesting questions but
we're not the worry here is of the soul
would be a harmony of body and its
elements and what are its elements well
you know drip thought in terms of like
this for element theories fire earth air
water and in terms of principles like
heat and cold dry and wet and things
like that
so the idea is when the body actually
comes apart than the harmony of those
parts is gonna come apart
I don't think about it if you if you
think that the soul is basically a
person mind or personality is basically
a function of we're probably located in
the brain what happens when you like get
in there and scramble somebody's brain
very personal
assuming that the paint body here well
you know the rest of their bodies
they're not that many more imagine you
actually like open up the time
dependence spoon took a wooden spoon
stir it around that's got a killer and
there won't be anything left unlike
reconstruct what does I can put your
your all your memories and your
personality on that on to like a
computer hard drive one of these sort of
science fiction things better watch out
for that hard drive that right somebody
smashes that hard drive that's you
you're going there's no no you made so
that's the worry there what's the other
we brought this up a little bit earlier
kept pace is concerned that this hole is
a little bit more complicated the soul
is like a beaver and the beaver has many
toes and the Weaver is even being right
Weaver's a little makes the coats and
the Weaver has had many coats over time
why because coats were out a lot quicker
right think about your shoes we don't
have a lot of floor of clothes but how
many pairs of shoes have been had in
your lifetime just up until that and I
know some of it is because you upgrade
your growing and all that your feet more
or less I think stop growing probably
when you're about 16 and hope they don't
keep on growing
so 16 to 18 16
2:19 how many pairs of shoes have you've
worn out there read Wow you must like
run a lot that's a lot what's up very
much yeah I I would say I've gone
through probably that she was pairs of
shoes that I've actually worn out in my
lifetime there's you know shoes you buy
for special occasions yeah but I'd like
worn out pairs of work boots all of the
army boots that they I have warm to
laughter they're wore out then that's in
about three four years well that means
that the person lasts a lot longer than
the article clothing right so in
relation to the article of clothing the
person should last almost forever but
now imagine the Weaver dies somebody
comes in and say I know he's not dead
look there's his coat hanging right
there I know that he lasts longer than
was covered with coats still there so he
must still be alive so the idea is that
the soul would be like the Weaver and
the coat would be like the body the soul
lasts longer that he'd give his body but
the worry is is that over time maybe you
know each time that it enters into the
body it loses a little bit of itself and
it starts to wear out and so eventually
towards the end
your soul is kind of you know worn out
or there's not too much of you and then
after a while it'll disappear like fairy
dust and
well that that's a plausible isn't it
that's conceivable so that's a real
worry
obviously the harmony part first so
Socrates says how should we actually
approach this and Socrates gives you
three different arguments against the
sole being a Harley these are actually
fairly good arguments against the soul
being a harmony they may not necessarily
eat you the soul being immortal but they
do at least get you the soul can't be
harmony
so let's think that the first argument
is first argument is let's take the
guitar and the harmony what exists first
yeah the guitar you know we could
actually think that it's a music shop
it's in a case and then somebody comes
in and picks it up and what's the sign
that used to be like a standing joke I
don't know if it still happens these
days anymore but used to be everybody to
go into the guitar store play stairway
that guitar people hate it because it
was like so they have to hear it and
everyday you know some kid coming in
there playing this song but until that
kid picks it up and starts playing
there's no harmony what's the deal with
the soul on the body though there's the
soul does this whole coming after the
body in Plato's view existed before it
existed before it and it sort of takes
on the body so the soul already can't be
like a harmony because the harmony
doesn't exist before the instrument this
whole other exists before the body so
this analogy can't possibly hold and he
says look either we give up the doctrine
of recollection in which case then we
could have this for this can't be the
case it can't be yeah
because we're actually the army actually
is is important
yeah but the actual like coordinating
sexist they existed before they the
Khazar came around ah sort of like in
our our minds or damaged you have played
it on other guitar yeah there we get to
that that issue about is it is it the
same chord and Plato this is the this is
a great example actually remember reason
that dialectic it was a great example of
you doing exactly what I was talking
about taking play don't flush it
yeah saying yeah it couldn't it be like
this instead and I if we had time I
explore that more they mail should
another video look at that but I want to
fly through these as quickly as possible
good question very good question
what's another argument against harmony
he says can a harmony oppose the
instrument could it be in a different
state than the instrument and I guess
you know you thought about guitars and
he thought about you know amplifiers you
could you could maybe think of feedback
that would destroy an instrument
couldn't you he doesn't think of that
but in most cases can harmony oppose the
instrument know does this whole ever
oppose the body
do you ever keep yourself from doing
things that your body desires to do or
make your body do things that it doesn't
want to do yeah yeah I mean any of us
you have to exercise it don't like it if
you like doing exercise your body wants
to do it but if you push your body
further than it wants to go then you're
actually in charge so the soul
relationship to the body is not again
like harmony the third the other thing
that he pursues with that is virtual
advice these are not terms we talked an
awful lot about this forth a little bit
virtue and vice it's a little more
complicated here there's something in
the soul
so if you're a generous person that's in
your soul if you're a just person that's
so if you're a greedy person that's in
your soul if you're a lustful person
that's in your soul that's a perfect
those are virtues and vices right and
virtues and vices sake it says we can
think of these as being ten like the
person has a disordered soul has a vice
the person who has an ordered soul has a
virtue now you ask yourself this
question can a soul be more of a soul
than it is or is all something like up
you know this is a cup destroy it the
quits being a cup at what point in time
could you like make this you know less
copy than other comes that's a cup that
kind of thing yeah it's supposed to be
now it's it's a mug because it actually
has a handle but so long it's got that
kind of shape that's right and the idea
is the soul it's either a solar it's not
small it's either one thing together
what about harmonies what do you know
about harpus think about back to your
music class when you're when you're kids
remember when you had to sing like
harmony parts and somebody's not on the
right note how does this sound
yeah it's actually a disharmony and
stuff worse than if they weren't singing
at all so harmony is admit of more of
less then these kind of our meetings in
our soul would admit more than us the
problem is if the souls of harmony then
you've got a harmony inside of the
Harmony or you get a discord inside of a
harmony and again when it comes to music
couldn't we conceive of this I think we
actually could Plato doesn't think that
you can't that's probably having to do
with music that's available
at that time if the soul can only be the
soul it can't be more of a soul or
lessons so having advice in it wouldn't
make it you know more of a soul or less
of a soul but it would make it less of a
harmony so this this view is not going
to work the soul itself can't be a
harmony although it can have harmonies
or Dysport yeah so what about it for
instance the soul either picked up or
dropped of ice or picked up or dropped
you wouldn't that either change the
harmony or reset the meaning of the army
well again Socrates is saying the soul
itself can't be more or less of a soul
right so if we were to say that that
it's you know picking up the the harmony
or loosening the heart of a or
however we want to put it then the soul
would admit of degrees this part minutes
more or less
so he doesn't want to say this whole
can't have harmony in it he just wants
to say the soul itself can't be in
harmony and if the soul itself can be
harmony then we don't worry about it
breaking down at death body breaks down
there is one other thing that he says
about that but I'm going to skip that
very quickly a second the last two
that's if we can run through the greater
Socrates and I'm gonna hand it available
for you and I learned about this that
that would help the opera's Socrates
says does this second worry is the
deeper and he says we have to think
about this in terms of the doctrine of
forms and how things stuff about
opposites so think about and I'll use
the example of greatness is small
fado is greater than simius he's larger
than semi s so he has greatness within a
me participates in greatness put fado
next to somebody who's even bigger than
him what's a Goliath right a little over
lieth and now feat it looks small
Sasha's would say that's because he's
participating now in small of us the
greatness has been driven out the
smallness is down there this is a little
bit tricky it's actually not you know if
you if you look at this argument and you
feel and there's something hinky about
this you probably should but let's
actually just try to see where he's
going with this this works for a human
coal to think about the fire fire is 1
so it has heat within itself it
participates in in hotness when cold
approaches one way you can actually put
out the fires by cooling things down
enough the green tea does made sense of
them you can you can cool the fire and
if you actually get it cold enough what
happens pop this in the fire yeah it
either goes away completely or it like
flees somewhere else right the fire
imagine the fire can like get up and
walk around so if we want to think about
life and death intercepts we have an
opposite and the opposite is coming in
the opposite drives out it forces to
either cease to exist or go somewhere
else
the thing that is replacement yeah is
the opposite to what
soul has life not only does this whole
half life the soul is what gives life to
the body the soul is a certain sense the
principle of life so when death
approaches we've left something out of
the picture when death approaches what
happens the solo retreats because the
soul cannot admit of death the body can
is not self life it can't be a soul and
not have life with them so the death
can't simply replace the life in there
the very nature of the soul is to resist
death now there is something wrong with
this argument and I'm not going to tell
you what it is unless it because I'd
like you to think about that and carry
out this process of dialectic with
yourselves maybe what I'll do is I'll
I'll create another form for that as
well you can try out some the answers
and see see what you think